OK
Choose some tasks according to the distributive principle.
And the distributive power reminds us simply that
if we have, say, a b times plus c, then we
we have to multiply a-in with this, we need to multiply or times
both of these numbers.
So this will be equal to a times b plus a times c.
There will be simple a b and plus times c.
And that's completely logical.
Take an example.
I would say 5 times 3 plus 7, so if we used it
for this sequence of operations, you would say it is
5 times 10.
So you would say that this is 5 times 10 that is equal to 50.
And we know that this is the correct answer.
Now let's use the distributive property that tells us
this will be equal to 5 times, which is 15 plus 5
times 7, that is 35.
And 15 plus 35 is still 50.
If we had only multiplied by 5 with 3, we would win 15,
and then adding 7, the answer would be wrong.
We multiply the five times that we have, should
we multiply that two data.
Because you actually multiply the sum of these two.
However.
Use this to solve these tasks.
Let's do A.
So we have 1/2 times x minus y minus 4.
Then we will multiply 1/2 with the other two.
So it will be 1 / 2x minus 1 / 2y minus
4, and we finished it.
Let's do it and C.
We have 6 plus x minus 5 plus 7.
So, actually, we have nothing here
distribution that we can use.
We can simply remove the brackets.
6 plus this thing here, is the same as 6 plus x plus
minus 5 plus 7.
Or we can see it as a 6 plus - Share
this here is 2, right?
Minus 5 plus 7 is 2, 2 plus 6 is 8, so
becomes 8 plus x.
OK.
That's not all that bad.
This was C.
Let's do it and E-in.
We have 4 times m plus 7 minus 6 times 4 minus m.
Use the distributive property.
4 times m is 4m plus 4 times 7 is 28.
And we can do this in two ways.
Let's do this first. We may have minus
6 times 4 is 24.
6 times minus m is minus 6m.
And note that I could say just minus 6 and
to have here plus, but I do this in two steps.
I do it first 6 and then I'll do minus 1.
And so we will have 4m plus 28 and then you
distribute the negative sign.
All this can be seen as minus one of this.
Less than 1 time 24 is minus 24.
Less than 1 time minus 6m is plus 6m.
Now we go and m-in. 4m plus 6m is 10m.
And then the ascertainment. 28 minus 24, that is
equal to plus 4.
Let's go further.
Use distributive law to simplify
the following fractions.
We will do the second.
So the first is 8x plus 12 broken for 4.
So the cause that is said to be the personality
it is, in fact, to divide these
all with 4.
And to divide this all by 4, you would not want to divide each one
one by one with 4.
Or you can even see that, what we have is like that
multiply 1/4 times 8x plus 12.
These two things are equal.
And you divide each with 4, here
multiply each with 4.
If you do this, this is the same as 8x broken for 4
plus 12 broken for 4.
In one way, make the collection of fractions from the back.
And then 8 is divided by 4 and we will have,
we have 2x plus 3.
This is a way of solving it.
Or we can even choose this.
1/4 times 8x is 2x, plus 1/4 times 12 is 3.
However, we have the same answer.
C.
We have 11x plus 12 broken for 2.
Like here.
We can say that this is like 11. We can write
that's 11 broken for 2x, if you want.
Or 11x broken for 2, too.
Plus 12 breaks for 2 plus 6.
And let's do the last one.
E.
This looks interesting.
We have a negative sign before and then we have 6z
minus 2 broken for 3.
One of the ways to solve it is similar to
this is equal to minus 1/3 times 6z minus 2.
These are both equal.
Correct?
This is a minus 1/3.
You can imagine putting a 1 in here.
Correct?
Less than 1/3 times 6z minus 2.
And then you will use the distributive feature.
Less than 1/3 times 6z will be minus 2z.
And minus 1/3 times minus 2, as the minuses cancel each other
we will flip plus 2/3.
And that's over.
.